el nuevo gobierno de Italia será
recordado por ser la administración más
conservadora desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y la victoria de la coalición de
la derecha en los comicios legislativos
del 25 de septiembre no solo hizo
triunfar a Georgia meloni con su partido
los hermanos de Italia como el más
votado que ahora asumirá el cargo de
primera administrar el país después de
los comicios las cámaras del parlamento
también eligieron a dos presidentes con
valores ultraconservadoras
primero el senado la cámara alta eligió
a Ignacio la rusa como su líder
cofundador de los hermanos de Italia con
melón y este siciliano de 75 años ha
sido un activista de la extrema derecha
durante toda su vida antiguo ministro de
defensa de verlusconi la rusa es También
conocido por coleccionar recuerdos
fascistas y al día siguiente la cámara
baja de diputados dominó a lo Renzo
Fontana como presidente un estrecho
Aliado de salvini y devoto católico
conocido por sus posiciones antiorto
contra el matrimonio homosexual y por
sus comentarios amistosos con la Rusia
de Vladimir putino a pesar del perfil
mayoritariamente conservador de este
nuevo parlamento italiano ya se han
observado tensiones dentro de la
coalición gubernamental con los partidos
de Silvio berlusconi y Mateo salvini
negándose a desaparecer detrás de
Georgia meloni una nueva administración
que llega además en un contexto de
desafíos para la tercera economía de la
zona Euro incluida una deuda que ha
alcanzado el 150% de su pib una recesión
inminente y precios
récord en la energía provocados por la
Guerra de Ucrania